the four questions of the pandemic after
almost two years of living with cover 19
we need to ask ourselves about what
risks we're willing to take as a
community by dan in
um
so um he's the first paragraph like many
other pulpit rabbis i found myself in
march 2020 facing a lot of unknowns so
he's a rabbi in san francisco
um who was uh you know did not did not
um
did not see his congregation for a while
um and
the whole essay is excellent and i
recommend it but i wanted to read just
he asks four questions
here and i want to ask i want to
repeat one of them in his answer
what responsibility do we have as a
religious community to assist people in
alleviating irrational or
disproportionate anxiety and fears
during times of war social upheaval
community anxiety and concern should the
synagogue not be the place to gather in
solace for a hug a respite from work
life a place to take in a moment a sweet
prayer what is the risk of not having
that
is there more virtue to be found in
spending more time pouring over graphs
of aerosol transmission spread among
low-risk populations than in looking at
the staggering increase in teen suicides
depression mental health crises and
learning loss
that's just super powerful and i know
you know we we know some people who are
um
not religious don't have faith not
believers who are looking
um for exactly this for places of of
solace
uh where they can go and be around
people and
treat others and be treated with respect
as human beings and
even most places of religious worship
are requiring
your proof of acts at the door
and
um
increasingly i'm hearing many are not
but
this this i would ask i would ask all of
us to consider this question that rabbi
ain asks us
and
the
other piece that i wanted to share from
tablet
before you move on from there i just
want to point out another place where
you can detect that what we are doing
has nothing to do with what's good for
our health or what's good for the public
health has to do with the absurd way
that we have dealt with
natural immunity and i believe natural
immunity
we will never know whether it has to do
with the fact that you and i were
shouting about natural immunity for many
many months
i suspect we contributed to the
awareness of it but nonetheless natural
immunity has finally dawned on people
but it is frequently presented in the
context of
the comparison to the vaccines etc etc
what we don't understand and you know
omicron has changed the picture a little
bit because there are a certain number
of re-infections but
the
fact of some huge fraction of the
population
for whom the pandemic is no longer a
direct threat
irrespective of how much risk they face
to begin with the fact that they got it
got through it means that those people
you know to the extent that we have
people isolated right
maybe we have old people isolated
because they can't afford to get it but
you know who can non-isolate them people
in their religious communities for
example who've had covid right there are
plenty of solutions and the idea that
what you're going to do is hand down
from the federal government some
dictat that results in a religious
community effectively you know turning
into a two-tiered society and not
doing anything rational from the point
of view of protecting the elderly
because really what you're doing is just
deciding who was compliant with a
vaccine that does not prevent
contraction or transmission of the
disease does not reduce viral load
it's in it's an incredible waste of an
opportunity the opportunity cost of not
doing the rational thing was
incalculable
so anyway that yes the idea that the
religious community has a purpose that
its purpose
couldn't possibly be more important than
in a moment like this and that we are
going to hobble that entity rather than
do something rational rather than come
up with an actual test that lets us
figure out who does have natural
immunity and get on with
life yeah no and i think um
many
liberals uh you know again of which we
are too
um
take pride in our secularism
and uh it has been i mean this is
something we've talked about for decades
and we write about in hunter-gatherer's
guide
but you know religion
has a purpose
and those who are religious
have historically done far better for
themselves and their families than those
who have not been and so the very smug
position of many secular liberals
that if you are religious you have
demonstrated that you're not educated or
you're
not smart uh or
you you don't believe in science
uh is frankly an ideological position
that itself is uninvestigated it's one
of these conclusions that many people on
the left have accepted without further
thinking through what it actually means
so
um you know what what is you know what
are some of the values of religion
it's not just about believing in a god
by any means and i mean i remember
hearing this
hearing that from religious scholars at
evergreen actually and it was shocking
to me you know people who had devoted
their lives and who were themselves
religious
um
devoted their lives to the study of uh
scholar of religious texts and to
understanding what they meant who would
say
um
there you know there are plenty of us
who identify exactly as as i do who
actually will say
it's not about god and there i'm sure
there are others who will who will
disagree with that conclusion but the
idea that the only way that you can um
you can
discuss religion and its value is to um
is to talk about to talk about a
singular deity is really an
uninvestigated ideological position that
many on the left hold yeah it's a it's a
crazy position yeah i've i've argued
that the um
the claims about the
way the universe functions that exist in
almost all religions
are effectively like the trunk of a tree
right they are a mechanism right is the
trunk of a tree photosynthetic no what
is its purpose to get the leaves of the
tree above leaves that they compete with
to do photosynthesis so the point is it
is a means to an end
but the point of religion is
what it does
and you know we have to be careful with
this because
you know the position i've tried to lay
out be careful because xylo and phloem
are also in the trunk of the tree and
they're delivering nutrients no i mean
xylem and phloem are necessary to get
the business end of the
photosynthetic apparatus connected to
the
the roots and all but
but the point is we have to be careful
because
you can overdraw this message and in
fact what we say in our book is we live
in an environment so radically different
even from the environment that we were
born in yeah the farther back you go to
draw wisdom yes there's some timeless
stuff but much of what exists in these
past compendiums of wisdom
is out of phase with the place we live
and so it's not like we can say look the
point of religion is that it helps you
know how to live it did but it helped
you know how to live in an environment
we don't live in anymore so we have a
new problem but the solution isn't
secularism in the sense that finally
we're over that religious thing the
problem is what do we do now that our
religions aren't quite up to the task of
telling us how to deal with modernity
[Music]
you